il ya 40 ans en france c'était le front
populaire ce gouvernement qui a duré
exactement entre deux étés mais ce qu'on
a un peu oublié je crois c'est le
sillage kbc cette époque là c'est à dire
son parfum c'est sa musique particulière
c'est ses chansons on se souvient de la
naissance des congés payés mais on a
peut-être oublié que c'était vraiment là
la révélation des vacances pour beaucoup
qui n'en avait jamais eu qu'ils
n'étaient jamais allés au bord de la mer
et puis c'était évidemment le temps de
la guerre d'espagne mais un temps aussi
où beaucoup oublié ce que représentait
exactement et hitler et staline ont les
français chantait beaucoup en ce temps
là et pour moi il y a un maire qui est
comme l'indicatif de ct au 30 d'avis
jamais en 15 ans ou moi
mais pendant que nos champions ça sur
les routes que nous fréquentions les
auberges de la jeunesse et bien nos
parents nous disaient les enfants amusez
vous profitez en car on ne sait pas de
quoi l'avenir sera fait effectivement
trois ans après et bien a cité la guerre
[Musique]
deux étés pour l'espoir
le front populaire et des loisirs
[Musique]
je me souviens qu'en 1929
je suis à déployer curseur des luttes
ouvrières dans cette prison j'étais le
seul employé à faire grève le 1er mai
naturellement ça se savait j'ai débuté
ici là
pour 12e et al dans un numéro qui
étaient les demandes d'emploi il faut
situer l'époque 29 31
c'était le début de la grande crise
on embauche et les ouvriers pour la
ville de paris on a beau chez les
cantonniers les menuisiers égoutiers et
c'est une époque où il fallait attendre
six ou sept ans pour avoir un poste de
balayeur d'opinion en 1931 vous êtes
ouvrier chez renault
oui et le soir eh bien le soir c'était
bon elle désire enfin c'était de la
peinture donc je travaillais pour gagner
ma vie et je rêvais à bercy 7 heures
d'être libre et d'aller soit dans un
cours de dessin de sculpture ou chez moi
pour faire de la peinture c'est ce souci
véritable il ya des choses très
intéressantes quand on aime quand on a
appris le métier pas de retard hier moi
j'ai appris plusieurs métiers c'était
plâtrier j'étais cimentier est bien dans
le prolétariat on apprend à travailler
le travail fait achevée et ça c'est
important dans la vie d'un peintre par
la suite est très important parce que il
ya la technique si vous voulez vous avez
des mains qui s'affairent les choses
parce que j'ai fait je suis beaucoup
plus tard l'homme à la cigarette parce
qu'un ouvrier quand il fait une
cigarette
il a les mains assez épaisses par mais
il le fait avec une extrême élégance
sans rature parce qu'il sait ce que
c'est que la matière justement une des
préoccupations peut être la grande
préoccupation des artistes et écrivains
révolutionnaire dont fait partie était
exprimé le prolétariat pour nous on ne
pouvait pas dissocier la peinture
moderne des espoirs de la classe
ouvrière et on veut lui ont volé non pas
l'obliger à regarder cette peinture mais
quand même qu'ils s'y reconnaissent
alors donc un désir d'aller vers une
peinture murale parce qu'on fond
la peinture moderne elle a en elle
collait à la rhonelle la peinture murale
d'ailleurs cette simplification cette
exaltation de la couleur cette fausse
exaltation d'un forme au fond c'est pour
faire enfin l'art de la rue hanson l'art
qui s'adresse à la foule
non pas l'art des galeries ou pour
collectionneurs l'arc qui s'adresse à la
multitude et qui porte en elle quelque
chose de vivant enfin de dynamique qui
exprime enfants ce désir secret parce
que le dites pas que vous préfériez
désir bafin ici ces gens-là espérer
qu'ils s'y reconnaître est allée du même
souffle que lui et ça s'est inquiété un
sonore notre pensée cette époque la
façon de littérature ce soit dans la
peinture la sculpture dessin vous
appeler pierre olié de marie charme et
je crois que mon appel pomme oui c'est
exact ce sont les initiales et c'est une
habitude depuis longtemps en 1936 dans
les années qui précèdent le front
populaire dans les mois qui précèdent le
front populaire quelles sont vos
activités et bien j'étais étudiant
j'étais étudiant aux beaux-arts de lyon
est
je m'occupais de j'étais président
exactement d'un groupe d'étudiants
chrétiens et en 34 j'étais également
président d'un groupe d'étudiantes y
fasciste ce groupe m'a permis de faire
la connaissance du monde ouvrier car
nous avions comme service d'ordre des
cimentiers des gens du bâtiment qui
faisait le service d'ordre pour nos
manifestations
quand je suis arrivé à paris j'ai eu une
chance extraordinaire c'est d'arriver
dans une période où il y avait une
climat de fraternité extraordinaire et
où on rencontre est tout de suite des
copains et nous étions toute une bande
là dans cette bande il y avait des gens
qui n'étaient pas connues un pion du
lycée chaptal qui s'appelait jean louis
barrault il y avait des gens du groupe
octobre les deux frères prévert raymond
bussières max maurice marcel duhamel
enfin tous les débutants du groupe
octobre et tout normalement on
s'intégrer là et les activités en dehors
du travail de chacun c'était la soirée
ensemble
la soirée ensemble 36 à donner des
occasions extraordinaires
nous étions passionnés de vivre et c'est
pourquoi en ce dieu aussi bien de
politique que de godard et de tous ainsi
tonné on a fondé avec quelques camarades
un groupe de théâtre plus exactement les
gens l'ont appelé un groupe de théâtre
alors que pour nous c'était un groupe
toussaint un groupe d'agitation de
propagande d'agit-prop puisse 14 qui
avait lancé sa en allemagne c'est à dire
que au lieu
de faire une distribution de tracts dans
la rue nous faisions une distribution de
tracts oraux y avait un événement
quelconque qui se passait on faisait un
texte et on allait le dire dans la rue
parmi les gens exagèrent et ce groupe ne
s'est jamais occupé vraiment d'art il
s'occupait de la révolution on voulait
faire la révolution pour après demain et
nous avons eu la chance de rencontrer à
monsieur un jour sur le conseil devait
encore duriez qui m'a dit vas voir un
certain monsieur il al'air biz il a
l'air intéressant salaire d'un vrai
personnage il s'appelle jacques prévert
et nous avons rencontré jacques prévert
et de ce jour jacques a écrit à la
commande
tenez un exemple précis un jour
j'apprends qu'il y avait une grève qui
venait de déclencher chez citroën
j'avais cet avantage comme j'étais à
l'hôtel de ville rouge à vélo le
téléphone gratuit j'alerte les copains
et j'alerte surtout prêts verts eelv est
un deux heures de l'après-midi et jeudi
à jacques à une greffe chez citroën il
faire pour nous faire un texte sur
citroën et le soir on travaillait tous
sauf les chômeurs naturellement on se
retrouve à 6 heures à la maison des
syndicats
là où il ya maintenant le le bel
immeuble du parti communiste d'hyères
assez proclame et dessablement des
baraquements et on se retrouve là avec
un texte de jacques on apprend ce texte
jack et à 8 heures on le donne et devant
les ouvriers de chez diderot et
d'agréable l'internet ce texte
je me souviens c'est terrible c'est un
texte qu'on a perdu
qui a été perdu et part et il convient
de le retrouver d'ailleurs la partie de
ragga qui revenaient un joueur qui a
donné ce texte à prévert donc je vais
vous le citez de mémoire surtout le
début mais il était suffisamment bon je
m'en souvienne
on avait une petite copine blonde
charmante qui arrivent et qui d'un
c'était l'époque pour vous dire
c'était l'époque où citroën faisait de
la réclame sur la tour eiffel
c'est iter oen cydroine ctrc une belle
réclame sur la tour eiffel quand même et
le il y avait des petites copines
d'ailleurs qui rentrait et qui disait
dans tes père modeste et en plus gêné
qui disait à la porte des maisons closes
c'est une petite lueur qui publie
quelque chose de discret une petite
lumière un quinqua et je rentrais en
disant oui mais sur paris endormi une
grande lumière monte sur la tour c'est
la lumière du bordel capitaliste avec le
nom du taulier qui brille dans la nuit
c'est un joli texte non j'utilise et
bien tu voulais dire ou alors il ya tout
de même une chose qui nous frappe
aujourd'hui quand on parle avec des gens
comme vous c'est que il y avait à cette
époque là une qualité d' enthousiasme de
genèse de gaieté d'un tube facile
figurez-vous en 1925 je voulais j'ai
commencé en 1927 la révolution russe
avait 10 ans vient pas eu la hongrie
bien voyez la tchécoslovaquie y avait
près le pacte germano-soviétique toutes
les chaudes et est d'une clarté et d'une
simplicité ce qu'ils ne portaient pas
quand nous étaient débordés
mais vraiment nous le pensions
sincèrement et je crois que nous avions
raison de le penser
monnet tout était simple
tout était clair j'avais raison de
s'exciter sur indique ce un disque
d'armstrong
quand même j'avais demain j'avais raison
de m'exciter sur la peinture de monsieur
picasso ou sur le surréalisme qui
m'apprenait ce qui était freud entre
autres vous venez tout ça a été d'une
clarté d'une limpidité que encore une
fois je disais aux gens d montrez nous
que nous avons tort démontré que les
raisons pour laquelle nous pensons ça
c'est une mauvaise raison et personne
n'a pu me dire que c'était de ma mère
[Musique]
mais voilà c'est grâce à l'en avant
guingamp
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame programme cieux et non monsieur
provins vous étiez tous les trois
ouvriers en 1930 dans les années 30
juste avant le front populaire
on s'est fait mal unités du climat qui
régnait dans une usine à cette époque là
alors qu'elle était ce climat pour vous
monsieur hinault par exemple de
travailler chez renault je crois je
travaille chez renault en effet depuis
j'ai vécu pratiquement un an un peu plus
d'un an avant les grèves de 1936 le
climat qui régnait ce tacle ua de
pression parce que on n'a aucun droit
dans une usine dans un grand atelier où
nous étions deux mille personnes on
n'avait pas le droit de fumer par
exemple ce qui faisait que l'on allait
comme des comme des enfants fument une
cigarette dans les terres on ne savait
jamais quand on allait terminer sa
journée parce qu'on vous demandait un
quart d'heure avant de partir de faire
une heure de plus par foued on ne savait
en revanche jamais non plus si on allait
travailler l'homme parce qu'on pouvait
fort bien vous dire dans le courant de
la journée ben mon vieux j'ai plus rien
reviens demain
alors ça vous donne déjà une idée de ce
climat d'incertitude dans lequel on
vivait madame provins vous avez commencé
à travailler à quel âge à peine 13 ans
j'avais eu un livret de travail pour
commencer parce que
on ne pouvait pas travailler avant 13
ans un livret travail ou sans certificat
d'études et certificat d'études je ne
l'avais pas parce que à 11 ans 11 ans et
demi je n'allais plus à l'école en brut
et comme j'étais en bretagne je gardais
plutôt les vaches comme j'étais d'une
famille nombreuse
les huit enfants dont il n'était pas
question que je continue à aller à
l'école
et puis quand je suis arrivé ici j'ai
commencé à travailler pendant quatre ans
dans une usine de caoutchouc
pendant quatre ans poussée que cette île
bagne et puis après je suis rentré
travailler aux isolants en 34 je vous
avais l'impression les uns et les autres
madame provins monsieur provins que il
vous restait du temps pour penser à
votre situation personnelle et pour
penser à votre loisir ça doit être comme
toi
probablement on fait un peu de sport
très peu parce qu'évidemment sa fatigue
et puis ma fouet le reste du temps on
allait au cinéma
j'aimais bien aller au bal seulement
bien sûr j'aurais bien aimé aller au bal
mais on aime bien être quand on va au
bac on aimait bien être ghana ranger
aussi et c'était toujours des
difficultés qu'on connaissait parce que
les chaussures c'était peut-être pas
cher mais enfin on était plusieurs
soeurs mais tout le monde n'en avait pas
alors des fois dans ceux prêtés l'une à
l'autre ce qu'on avait pour pour que
tout le monde puisse avoir ce qu'il faut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
o o
ra entre amis chantons la titre ont en
[Musique]
commun qu'on ne rentre pas
bien oui j'ai jacques prévert m'avait
confié le manuscrit d'un poème intitulé
printemps-été 36 et généreux mort
terrible c'est que j'ai perdu ce
manuscrit et que je ne crois pas et
qu'il ait été recopiées en entier je me
souviens pour la voir interpréter assez
souvent dans des veillées d'auberges de
jeunesse ou dans des usines occupées par
les grévistes du début j'espère ne pas
trop le massacre et j'espère surtout que
jacques si l'entente me pardonnera ça
s'appelait printemps-été 36 le travail
le travail le travail à la chaîne
soudain le travail casse sa chaîne pose
son outil et tous les travailleurs se
réveille avec lui et pousse un grand cri
la grève la grève partout partout la
grève c'est une grève qu'on n'a pas vu
souvent et le capital grincent des dents
savez c'est un beau souvenir
je me souviens la grève à à démarrer
précisément dans l'atelier où je me
trouvais s'il fallait dire d'un mot
l'impression qu'ils m'en reste je
pourrais vous dire on s'est découvert
mutuellement on a vu des camarades de
travail qui me disait jamais rien avec
qui on avait des rapports très cordiaux
bonjour bonsoir
qu'est ce t'as fait dimanche mais ça
n'allait pas plus loin
bord on a vu ces mêmes devenir tout à
fait différent et au cours de la
quinzaine de jours environ qu'on a
passées dans l' usine surtout la nuit
on n'arrêtait pas de discuter tout y
passait on avait un espoir
extraordinaire vous avez le souvenir la
province votre inoccupés oh oui un
souvenir
d'abord je vois encore comme si c'était
aujourd'hui comme si c'était vous
je vois ce monsieur qui nous a d'abord
annoncé que qu'on a légué on allait
faire la grève à partir d'une heure et
je le vois encore en train de nous
expliquer qu'on allait nous réunir et
puis qu'une fois qu'on serait réuni
qu'il pourrait revenir à notre place
pour nettoyer nos machines
et puis nettoyer nos places comme il
faut parce que qu'il ne fallait surtout
pas que pendant les grèves qui aucune
machine qui soit ni rouiller ni
détériorer il fallait vraiment que tout
l'atelier soit nickel je me vois encore
dans la cour ou dans les défilés tout
seul et surtout danser parce que vous
savez comme j'étais encore jeune de ce
temps là je me vois surtout en train de
danser dans la cour et puis tout seul
[Musique]
c'est la plus grande fête populaire que
j'ai connu tous les ouvriers occupait
tout y est pas un magasin avec trois
employés qui n'était pas eu peur
d'envoyer tout ça se passait dans la
meilleure bonne humeur les communistes
en galets socialiste en lui dans ton
blum
c'est vrai qu'on les quêtes socialiste
bientôt cas j'en sors vieux connaît
arabe l'egypte mais tout le monde en ce
moment mais il était là il occupait les
geôles
le gouvernement présentera dès demain
devant lee chang comprendre anne et le
programme populaire parmi les projets
donc la nôtre aldo au immédiat et une
demandera aux du temps de voter avant
leur séparation la semaine de 40 air
décontracté des congés payés
cette année les principales réformes
réclamées par le monde brive et je vous
dirais que quand il ya eu la fin de la
grève les congés payés
on avait encore du mal à réaliser que
c'était possible partir quinze jours en
vacances et toucher la paye en revenant
quelqu'un qui tous les vendredis
attendait ça paye il ne pouvait pas
s'imaginer que et j'étais pas la seule
on pouvait pas s'imaginer que c'est elle
et que ça lui être les vacances
et puis mon salaire avait été doublée
mois comme j'étais manoeuvre je
travaillais aux pièces on avait des
cadences on peut dire infernale et bien
après les cadences ont été réglés on
était plus sain et puis on faisait que
40 heures donc pour moi ça a été d'abord
davantage de loisirs parce que ne
travaillant pas le samedi
on avait quand même davantage de temps
pour pour sortir un peu et comme il y
avait aussi une
davantage de rentrées d'argent mais les
congés payés je le vois aussi comme si
c'était aujourd'hui on est parti à
blonville sur mer à côté de deauville
comme ma mère elle avait un frère là bas
parce qu'ils n'étaient encore pas
question d'aller à l'hôtel ni même au
restaurant on est tous à enfants on a
été passé qu'un jour là bas qu'ils sont
on peut passer des choses qu'on ne peut
pas oublier avec les cousins et puis des
cousines on allait se baigner
on se promenait et puis une chose qui
m'est aussi rester mon nom vous avez
amené aux trente courses parce qu'il y
avait des courses à deauville va vous
savez des ouvriers on n'avait jamais vu
ça nous a menés aux épis nous présenter
aux comptes d'intel aux comptes intel
ces beignets c'est cécile et ça vous
pensez qu'on était fier en revenant à
l'atelier de dire on a été au champ de
courses de deauville enfin je vous dis
c'est des choses inimaginables
et puis après un raid après je me suis
marié et c'est là que j'ai été père mon
voyage de noces sur la côte d'azur enfin
on l'a fait que six mois après mais
enfin pour moi ça a été encore aussi une
chose inoubliable parce que rien que de
penser que j'allais manger au restaurant
pendant quinze jours
chose que je n'avais jamais fait je
n'avais jamais mangé au restaurant de
votre vieux tueur de ma vie entière et
j'allais j'avais vingt ans passés de ce
temps là si on disait ça aux jeunes
maintenant il aurait presque du mal à le
croire mais c'était comme ça c'était
comme ça pour moi puis pour beaucoup
d'eau lors mon voyage sur la côte d'azur
c'est encore été un voyage une image in
et en même temps ce voyage sur la côte
d'azur en province étaient c'était votre
lune de miel
c'était net d'une guigne à luiz qui
avait six sept mois qu'on était marié
alors donc c'était la belle vie qui
commençait
[Musique]
d'où ces congés payés pour vous c'est
traduit comment ouais ses congés payés
on en avait beaucoup beaucoup discuté
pendant ces fameuses me qu'on avait
passé à la boîte
alors moi j'étais sur la côte d'azur
pourquoi sur la côte d'azur c'est la
meilleure bien sur le climat que je ne
connaissais pas mais enfin quand je
savais qu'il était merveilleux c'est
aussi un peu le rêve savez jamais assez
souvent au cinéma c'était partie de mes
loisirs et il y avait d'innombrables
films l époque tu monteras la côte
d'azur
justement cet aspect du rêve enfin je
voulais voir ça alors je suis donc parti
j'ai séjourné dans un petit hôtel dans
la banlieue de cannes et je me suis mis
à déambuler dans cette côte d'azur a
baigné enfin vivre une ville qui n'est
pas du tout celle dont j'avais
l'habitude
alors j'ai découvert ça mais j'ai
découvert aussi autre chose j'ai vu
là-bas un clivage social plus visible il
est peut-être pas plus réel je n'en sais
rien mais plus visible que celui que
nous avons dans la région parisienne
si je prends cannes par exemple quand le
soir on se promène sur la croisette à la
terrasse des grands hôtels
l'éclairage les toilettes des femmes
les gens smoking blanc tout ça c'est
féerique se renvoient la balle
commencera serait entrer là dedans moi
ouais ouvriers de chez renault il n'y a
pas besoin de me l'interdire
vraiment ça m'a fait prendre conscience
je l'avais déjà c'est vrai mais enfin si
vous voulez ça renforcer cette confiance
ça va déterminer davantage peut-être à
essayer de faire qu'il ya un peu plus de
justice dans la société
dès 1919 le très jeune léon blum avait
senti l'importance du loisir le
prolétariat avait t-il dit qu'ils aient
la force agissante du monde parfait on
travaille a droit si je puis dire à
toutes les fleurs que ce travail fait
naître à toutes les jouissances de la
culture à tout les jouissances dollar
c'est un problème capital bien je pense
que cette sorte prescience de léon blum
enfin cette expression de 1919
correspond parfaitement à l'esprit qui
l'animé
lorsqu'il a désigné les eaux et
madeleine lagrange à la direction du
secrétariat d'état aux loisirs léo
lagrange était un jeune député du nord
qui était très unitaire
c'était un grand frère c'était pas notre
ministre c'était un grand frère qui
venait s'asseoir sur l'herbe avec nous
qu'ils venaient discuter à l'auberge
manger à table dans le réfectoire de
l'auberge
je fais que nous prêts un [ __ ] tôt à
travers l'europe et avoir des dizaines
on est dans la réalité est allé mais il
a réalisé il nous a aidés à réaliser ce
que nous rêvions
c'est à dire qu'il nous a apporté des
crédits il les a mis à la disposition il
a fait confiance aux organisations pour
mettre ce à la disposition des jeunes et
il a toujours demandé que ça corresponde
au désir réel
des jeunes de l'époque les auberges de
la jeunesse était né au début des années
sous l'impulsion notamment de marc
sangnier à partir de 1936 elles vont se
multiplier
madame grün mumba l'un auprès de léo
lagrange anime le mouvement avec une
très grande ouverture d'esprit
nous avons rencontré l'une de ses
collaboratrices de nice cresswell qui
fut en même temps une hagist fervente
je pense que par exemple le même
maintenant tous les jeunes qui ce qu'ils
chantent avec des guitares ne savent pas
que le départ a été les auberges de
jeunesse chacun avait une flûte une
guitare et un harmonica on chantait des
chansons de trenet on chantait ma blonde
enfin c'était je crois que c'était à la
fois une y avait une possibilité de
dialogue sur le plan social et politique
avec tous les jeunes qui naturellement
cherchait s'agitait y réfléchissait et
puis il y avait cette joie et cette
liberté enfin cette ce plaisir de
chanter ensemble
votez
vraiment aller vivre la langue
[Musique]
cette découverte des besognes presque
ménagères fait ensemble la vaisselle la
cuisine l'épluchage pendant qu'on
chantait à plusieurs voix c'était
vraiment ah oui c'était pour moi il ya
eu avant les auberges et depuis les
auberges
[Musique]
c'était une découverte pour absolument
tous
une découverte qui repose cependant sur
un fait c'est que les jeunes avaient une
origine terrienne très proches et ils
avaient tous des parents à la campagne
il arrivait tous deux leur province et
ils retrouvaient ce qui avait été
l'idéal de leurs enfants ce qui avait
été comme moi dans une école primaire
d'un petit village de 300 habitants
eh bien c'était assez plaisant de
retrouver la nature c'est à pierre jamet
que nous devons ces très belles
photographies d'auberges de nature et
robert gist lui-même en savoie il est
aussi à l'époque danseurs animateurs de
chorales et il ne s'est pas
naturellement qu'il deviendra célèbre
quelques années plus tard dans le groupe
des quatre barbus bah ça c'est avec mon
partenaire de
deux voyages de stock mon ami pomme et
bien c'est sur une route sèche porte sur
la nationale 7 on était en train de
descendre vers le midi ce n'est pas
encore très encombré comme vous pouvez
voir une voiture était assez rare mais
enfin on y arrivait assez facile buck y
avait des matches entre vous willis est
arrivé les compétitions et qui
arriverait le plus vite là et c'est
arrivé en effet et alors remarqué qu'on
se mettait des chaussettes blanches très
toujours très soignée très tendu très
propre pour capter l'attention des
automobilistes pour le se rendre
sympathique rapidement et cette espèce
de signal alors un symbole reste par
contre puisque c'est lui qui jouit
oui bon ça c'est un intérieur d'auberges
de dons pomme avait décoré les murs il
dessine très bien ils s'aiment d'agilis
qu'envoyer de marche de flux bateau
grand air et l'harmonica et l'instrument
majeur à huy sur les hormones icasa
envahissent les auberges presque un peu
trop parce que c'est un instrument quand
il est pour très bien jouer un petit peu
fatigant et enrayer l' état d'un
magistral et on attend de voir éclore un
art magnifique la bouche
enfin ça fait partie du jeu voilà un
dessin de l'un des symboles pomme qui
vaut prévenir
oui ça c'est c'est pas me caresser et de
synthétiser tout ce qu'ils étaient mais
mes centres d'intérêt à l'époque c'est à
dire
le ski que j'apprenais en chambre avec
les livres d'emile allais l'aller les
chanteurs à la mode charles trenet
gilles et julien qui étaient des grandes
vedettes à l'épaule avait justement
justement arrêtons-nous sur gilles
julien
je crois qu'ils ont beaucoup marqué dans
votre vie mon coup beaucoup et en même
temps qu'ils étaient en voiture qui sont
très révélateurs de cette période du
front populaire il ya ces deux aspects
là en effet pour moi c'était les grands
chanteurs sais je voulais faire quelque
chose comme eux leur répertoire leur
façon de chanter en duo nous plaisait
infiniment et d'autre part ils ont été
les jeudis pour les chanteurs du front
populaire mais l'esprit des chansons
écrites par gilles était exactement dans
le sens de ce qu'on attendait à cette
époque lorsque est ce que vous vous ne
méritez un peu de choses mais il y en a
des chansons de gilles julien
enfin il y en a une qui s'appelle la
belle france et qui qui était peut-être
la plus représentative de ce climat
mais vous voulez quoi bon et bien voyons
ça dit sur la route du passé vois-tu
venir la france quelle belle garde ça
rigole on dénonce épouse à wimereux
découvrent leurs espérances
elle a des yeux étoiles et quand elle
marche elle danse forte en gueule
l'esprit race et qu'elle les requins les
ans sur la route dû passer les voitures
venir la france l'écart vif le pied
léger la rigole on rigole ondées sur la
route du match ibrahim
avant de les valider l'afrique dont des
noms c'est pour la fibre des couleurs
d'hesperange et la visualise en achètent
ans or tant que l'esprit s'agissait lors
qu'elle est en somme sur la route du
passé voiture de cinq ans le khalife
retracer la vie de la bido des villas au
jeu
les auberges ont été au premier plan
il n'y avait qu'à voir d'ailleurs la
place que tenait dans les journaux
opposé au front populaire les critiques
sur les auberges et qu'elle était et
critiquent ces critiques c'est que
c'était pour dire le mot le foutoir
premièrement il est impensable qu'en
france on mélange les garçons et les
filles sous le même toit
ça ne se fait pas on veut bien que dans
is a global ensemble samedi soir on veut
bien qu'ils se croisent dans la rue on
veut bien qu'ils aillent même où ça
commence et aller en classe ensemble
mais ça ne doit pas aller plus loin
d'autre part qu'est ce que c'est que ces
histoires de loisirs qu'est ce que c'est
que ces culottes courtes
qu'est ce que c'est que ces shorts
pourquoi pas tout nu est vraiment
c'était des attaques sans nom et d'une
violence extraordinaire d'une violence
qui était qui atteignait la violence
qu'il y avait dans les luttes politiques
pierre cot ministre delà de l'aviation
ministre de l'air étaient traités de
galoper sanglant parce que il avait
envoyé des avions pour les républicains
espagnols
mais léo lagrange ministre de la paresse
était très déçu exa avec la même
violence et les jeunes les jeunes des
auberges étaient considérés comme des
dépravés
on se fait mal l'idée de ce que pouvait
être la vie d'une jeune femme dans les
auberges la jeunesse en 1936 37
oui c'est à dire que d'abord nous avions
des shorts ce qui déjà était d'un show
quand elle qu'on m'a lancé des cailloux
dans des villages des pyrénées c'était
on m'a lancé des pierres des grosses
pierres même on m'a fait partie en un
village avait amené ma tante et nous
devions camper alors comme femmes ce qui
m'avait évidemment le plus
le plus frappé puis j'ai trouvé ça très
naturel très vite c'était justement
cette cette camaraderie et cette égalité
si vous voulez dans les rapports c'était
la première fois que je ne soupçonnais
pas ça avant et je crois d'ailleurs que
c'était très rare
c'était la première fois que je
découvrais qu'un garçon et une fille
c'est la même chose en fin de l'esprit
des auberges donner une liberté assez
exceptionnelle à cette époque là tout à
fait exceptionnelle même à cette époque
là mais il n'y avait pas d'érotisme vous
savez comme maintenant c'était une
liberté sexuelle qui faisait que si on
faisait l'amour ensemble c'est pas un
péché voilà par comparaison si vous
voulez à l'idée de péché qui avait
beaucoup de jeunes à cette époque là
s'ils avaient des relations sexuelles ou
même si flirtait vous comprenez c'était
tandis qu aux auberges la notion du
pêché ça n'existait pas c'était tout
était dans les faits joyeux et de bonne
santé enfin on était libre mais
capeletto exactement l'esprit agissent
qu'est ce que ça voulait dire l'esprit
hagist il s'est créé et il a évolué au
départ oms nous nous vantions d'avoir
l'esprit hagist je ne sais pas si ça
reposer sur des réalités très solide
il faut c'est seulement vers fin 37
quand l'afflux de jeunes travailleurs a
été absorbée et qu'ils se sont vraiment
intégré aux aubert à ceux des auberges
qui existait avant que l'esprit hagist a
commencé à se créer l'esprit agi c'était
d'une part un affranchissement vis-à-vis
de la génération précédente
c'est une chose c'était d'autre part
avant tout un fonds de pacifisme quelle
que soit l'option politique les jeunes
avaient pu prendre
il y avait avant tout un fonds de
pacifisme et qui
qui a laissé désemparés les jeunes des
auberges en trente neuf alors cette fois
est aussi très émouvant gourou oui c'est
vrai ce garçon là c'était un jeune
étudiant de 19 ans qui faisait partie de
mon groupe 18 ans et qui est un garçon
très doué et malheureusement il a été
déporté il est mort à auschwitz et il
avait énormément de talent il a écrit
des poèmes des choses très très belle je
croyais il a écrit un poème
particulièrement qui qui reflète bien
l'état d'esprit de cette jeunesse et
particulièrement du groupe dans lequel
nous vivions c'est vrai on était des
copains des vrais des vrais copains quoi
qui c'est mais voilà on était une bonne
douzaine et toute notre jeunesse
1 oui toute notre enfance tout notre
adolescence le meilleur le plus pur le
plus frais de ce qu'on avait dans le
coeur comme ça sans le faire exprès on
l'avait eue ensemble
[Musique]
et puis il ya eu la guerre
les guerres c'est contre tous les
copains vous le savez bien
on ne veut pas le taire les copains
c'est pas des militaires alors
alors quoi alors on a été séparée y en a
qui sont partis y en a qui sont restés
il y en a qui sont morts alors voilà
c'est tout ce qu'on voulait dire c'est
tout ce qu'on avait envie de raconter
c'est fini c'est fini mais c'est pas
triste
c'est pas triste quand on se souvient
quand on se souvient comme c'était bien
quand on était copains tous ensemble
[Musique]